all right guys we're at hockey Lane in
Singapore in my hands is the all-new
Oppo Reno 10 Pro Plus I've been testing
this for the past couple weeks we are
now releasing it in Singapore as of this
date July 12th it was released other
places in March May 24th but nonetheless
we're a little bit late but we still got
the phone in our hands here we're going
to talk about it how it compares to
other phones out there the picture
quality the image quality the video
quality
so let's get down to it
[Music]
now talking about this phone real quick
this is not a flagship device so we're
not going to treat it as such this is a
upper tier mid-range phone does that
make sense it will what I mean by that
it's a Snapdragon 8 plus gen one phone
it's on today's Gen 2 so there's a
little bit of difference on this uh the
cameras of course are good but they're
not as good as the find X6 Pro that
comes out from Oppo as well with the
Hasselblad technology et cetera et
cetera et cetera but let's go through
some of the specs real quick on this uh
storage we've got 256 gigabytes of
onboard storage we've got 12 gigabytes
plus four gigabytes of RAM so you can
say 16 gigabytes of RAM but it's got 12
plus 4 for whatever reason uh the
processor as I mentioned is the 8 plus
gen 1 Snapdragon processor we've got the
cameras we've got a 32 megapixel for the
front facing camera 58 and 64 megapixels
for the rear cameras as well screen size
is 6.74 inches and yeah 4700 milliamp
batteries so we're pretty much good to
go this is a very well specked phone
this has been a flagship last year but
every year changes so how does this
phone handle today's requirements from
our content creators from the
photographers out there
kind of the same as last year so a
little bit of a peek into the review
anyway let's go take a photo of this
beautiful mosque right here we're gonna
go to Pro mode we're going to maximize
the resolution
here we go
boom
wow it's a loud shutter
it's very very loud
I feel like I'm using a film camera
maybe that's the idea to go analog but
with a phone because you know the
younger generation likes film because
they discovered it Russ older people
were like yeah that's what we shot most
of our lives
it is what it is it's all full circle
that's sexy yeah yeah
promo baby
talking about the camera quality real
quick the portrait mode on the Oppo
phones is fantastic the way that it
separates your subject from the
background is very realistic uh the
colors out of this are really good as
well now there's no Hasselblad branding
on this phone like there is on other
Oppo phones but they could be using some
of that technology nonetheless or
there's some of that color science but I
mean the colors are neutral looks really
good a lot of sharpness a lot of detail
um just because this is not a flagship
phone per se doesn't mean that the image
quality isn't there these are Flagship
specs and Flagship images coming out of
this very very impressive great dynamic
range I've got no complaints with it
whatsoever and that's out of the rear
cameras now we're gonna do some
front-facing shots with the front you
know the selfie camera 32 megapixels
let's see how much detail it grabs on my
face of course we can touch up and all
that great stuff in there we'll try some
video as well so let's get down to it
all right
I'm going Porsche mode selfie going one
times you can go point eight times you
know because if you're one of the group
of people you want that point eight
times here's 0.8 portrait mode boom one
time
take a look at the image here wow the
skin retouching on this is legit you
still see the pores but it removes the
blemishes
actually this is pretty good I'm gonna
take a photo just real quick without any
um
any ports you can see the difference
whew
beautify me beautify me man it's h what
are you gonna do now we're gonna try
video on the front facing camera here's
the downside right and I don't get why a
lot of these Android phone makers don't
do this why isn't there 4K in this you
got to Snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 processor
in this it could handle 4k on the
front-facing camera why don't we have
this only 1080.
so I'm talking with a 1080 camera
I feel like I'm in
in 2012 2015
we gotta be opal we got to get up to
this pace here 4K should be the de facto
on all your front-facing cameras going
forward
I mean the only ones that I know they do
it so far are Samsung
Google
I think that's it even xiaomi doesn't do
it yet even with their you know 13 Ultra
no
and the opal with
the Reno 10 Pro Plus
only 1080 on front facing camera it's
quite sad but anyway here's the audio
quality so you get a sense of what I
sound like using the front facing camera
as well in case you want to do some tick
tocks or some Instagram reels you know
how it sounds
let's flip to the rear cameras and let's
see how they go for video so now I'm
testing out the rear cameras in 4k30 on
the Reno 10 Pro Plus obviously a little
bit of stabilization here how does the
video quality look how does the sound
of these microphones sound does it sound
natural does it sound synthetic or
digital let me know I'm taking a step
down did you see that step or was it so
smooth you thought I was walking on
carpet let me know in the comment
section below so this is the video
quality 4K 30.
out of the Reno 10 Pro Plus so as I'm
looking through my images here in my
video I noticed that it looks a little
bit more saturated than I like now
case in point a little bit of a tip in
case you do not know this most phone
screens out of the box come set very
highly saturated or Vivid especially on
Android phones Oppo has a lot of
settings inside of this you can adjust
that go to your screen color mode under
your display and brightness click on it
it's set to Vivid out of the box we
don't want Vivid that's not natural it
looks good sometimes when you're posting
it online if you're editing it can
really scoop your edits go to Pro mode
go to cinematic
P3 color gamut and now when you get into
your photos
everything looks a lot better
than what it did we paid for her to be
in the shot
the last minute of the shot she walked
right through it Zaki keep it and we got
a tour guide here they're going to talk
as well we pay for these people folks
this is a very highly very expensive
video shoot that we do here for Geek
culture we spent a lot of money for
these people all right
that's it
looking for a laptop that has buha and
portable
look no further than Zenbook 14x OLED it
features a large 70 watt hour battery
and stunning Nano Edge 14.5 inch 2.8 K
120 hertz OLED display powered by the
latest 13th gen Intel Core I9 CPU and
RTX 3050 GPU all packed in a thin 16.9
mm chassis that only weighs 1.5
kilograms so you can stay focused at
work or play for more information check
out asus.com
let's talk about the design and the
display on this device now the display
is quite beautiful it is not a 4K
display but it has good enough
resolution it's 1240 by 2772 so that's
going to give you about 451 PPI for your
pixel peepers out there it's an OLED
display HDR 10 plus 1 billion colors
1400 nits of brightness it's a very good
display as a matter of fact it's right
up there with a lot of other pseudo
Flagship phones out there on the market
no issues at all with that now does have
sort of that sort of curvature display
I'm not a big fan of this I wish all
displays were flat now I feel that
design language has been kind of been
there and it's gone now and it does make
using the phone a little bit finicky on
the edges especially if you're editing
photos but it is comfortable to use in
the hands now it is made out of metal
for the most part it has a sort of a
kind of a brushed Sheen look on the back
of it but it is a bit smooth to touch
and you've got this kind of this shiny
bezel around it which we've seen on
other phones but the camera bump for a
lot of people out there might be
thinking is it so big do I want to use
this is it going to rock on a table Yeah
but you can get a case with it it comes
with a case Inside the Box because
that's what Oppo does but I mean the
camera module looks really good very
Sleek the design language on this phone
is really nice it looks Ultra Premium I
mean opal's done a great job on their
phones for the past number of years and
this is just a continuity of that and
you can see powered by Mari silicone on
the bottom of it with your Periscope
zoom lens with that as well camera cut
out circle on the on the display right
there
doesn't get in the way it's nice I like
it that's the design of the farm
and
take a look at this real quick this is
how good the portrait mode is on this
phone and it looks just absolutely
natural to fall off this looks like it
was taken with a professional camera
that is very natural to 1.4 and then of
course you want to go into the editing
we've got all the adjuster we want we've
got some filters we got fresh
clear warm you know you can adjust these
if you want we had text pixel retouch
eraser all that stuff I mean this is a
really
not bad straight out of camera
man it's getting really good with these
phones out is that's legit
[Music]
thank you
all right so in terms of battery life
how does this perform on a daily basis
it's good but again depends on your
usage now of course you can adjust the
frame rates on this display higher frame
rates is going to take more battery 4
700 milliamp battery which is decent
it's going to get you through the day no
issues at all again this is a very thin
very small phone so if you're gonna be
doing a lot of video a lot of
Photography then you can do a quick
charge on this and there's quick
charging to this all opal phones have it
I think it says 100 Watts or whatever
the case may be it's very very fast so
that's not really much of an issue so
battery life to me is good but overall
just using the phone daily I mean it's a
nice phone to use and when I talked in
earlier on this video and I started to
talk about Flagship versus kind of a
mid-tier upper Range phone it works well
and most people on The Daily day-to-day
usage are not going to notice the
difference between this and let's say a
fine X6 Pro in terms of navigating the
menus opening up apps and doing certain
things now you're not going to get that
Hasselblad collaboration inside of this
does that make a big difference to some
people no it doesn't there's like for a
photography nuts like myself I like that
collaboration I like that hasslebot
color science I see a little bit of it
here but it's not exactly the same but
for the average person out there you
want a good solid Android phone I would
say this is wanted to heavily consider
and if you're comparing to other Android
phones out there in this price point I
would say maybe the xiaomi 13 Pro would
be the closest to it
and those would be quite neck and neck
anyway if you want to see that battle
the 13 Pro versus the Reno 10 Pro Plus
let us know in the comment section below
if we get enough comments to say yes we
want to see that battle we'll make that
video happen anyway guys if you like
this video subscribe to the channel and
check out more of our phone videos right
here